deutschland fährt runter kanzlerin
merkel ruft dazu auf die neuen core ohne
regeln einzuhalten china fährt hoch zehn
monate nach dem ersten virus ausbruch
feiert das ende der pandemie donald
trump oder joe biden der weg ins weiße
haus führt über die sogenannten swing
states
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten denn sport hat
heute norbert lehmann dabei kein
schillernder am tor von mir seit
mitternacht gelten sie die neuen
verschärften chor ohne regeln
sie laufen auf mehr zu hause sein und
weniger geselligkeit hinaus so will man
die zurzeit extrem schnelle verbreitung
des virus wieder verlangsamen damit das
gesundheitssystem nicht kollabiert und
so ändert sich gerade unser leben grob
gesagt bleibt alles was in richtung
freizeit geht ab heute zu restaurants
bars kino theater oder museen hotels
dürfen keine touristen aufnehmen
auch private kontakte sollen
runtergefahren werden in den meisten
bundesländern auf nur noch zwei
haushalte all das bis mindestens ende
des monats der große unterschied zum
frühjahr kitas schulen und geschäfte
bleiben offen an seinem stern
mittagspause in münchen viele ziemlich
alleine gemeinsam essen gehen geht nicht
mehr
der erste tag von vier wochen im
runtergefahren antivirus modus in ganz
deutschland grundsätzlich finde ich auch
richtig weil wir sonst denke von dem
fall nicht runter kommen die leute leben
auch mittlerweile damit auf arbeit man
sieht sich nicht mehr die leute werden
depressive den ganzen tag zu hause
arbeiten
man kann seine verwandten nicht mehr
sehen und ja es ist halt alles ein
bisschen erbärmlich ich denke dass
manche dinge wie zb gaststätten
sind geschlossen und so weiter nicht
nötig werden shoppen ist noch erlaubt
viel mehr aber nicht ins café gehen
kultur genießen kinobesuchen erst einmal
verboten ganz besonders heftig trifft es
die die ganz besonders hart gearbeitet
hatten etwa an hygiene konzepten
darüber hinaus mache ich mir natürlich
auch ein bisschen sorgen um das image
weil jetzt immer die gastronomien
kulturbranche und hoteliers quasi immer
als erstes geschlossen werden und das
suggerieren natürlich auch so ein
bisschen dass wir die treiber dieser
dieser infektionswellen sind
infektionswellen wo auch immer
durchbrechen das ist das erklärte ziel
denn die krankenhäuser füllen sich auch
die zahl der kogit intensivpatienten ist
wieder angestiegen auf 2256 zur stunde
aber die gute nachricht immer noch
tausende betten sind frei
das problem ist das fehlende personal
das kernproblem wird das pflegepersonal
seien aber eins muss man sagen das war
es vor der korona pandemie auch schon
warum sollen denn jetzt mehr plötzlich
pflegepersonal da sein und das ist doch
die kritische frage deshalb brauchen wir
jetzt im moment dringend eine maßnahme
dass der regelbetrieb heruntergefahren
wird damit also mehr pflegekräfte und
ärzte abgestellt werden können für die
korona krise die das ganze land wieder
so fest im griff hat am tag eins der
einschränkungen hat die bundeskanzlerin
an die verantwortung aller appelliert
und die menschen in deutschland dazu
aufgerufen die neuen regeln auch zu
befolgen
sie bedeuteten verzicht auf vieles was
das leben schön macht räumte angela
merkel ein
dies sei aber die voraussetzung dafür
einen erträglichen dezember zu haben
lars bohnsack über merkels auftritt vor
der hauptstadtpresse
es ist nicht so häufig dass die
kanzlerin vor die bundespressekonferenz
tritt und so ist ihr werben für die
neuen pandemie maßnahmen auch ein
zeichen dafür wie hoch der druck auf die
regierung mittlerweile ist kein mensch
hat sich sowas gewünscht nur wir können
ja nicht zusehen wie wir dann sozusagen
menschen
neben offensive die überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems machen in diese
situation möchte ich nicht kommen drei
viertel aller infektionen sind nicht
mehr nachverfolgbar deshalb seien die
massiven aber zeitlich begrenzten
kontakt beschränkungen so wichtig wenn
wir das einen monat mit aller konsequenz
durchhalten kann das in dieser zweiten
welle ein wellenbrecher sein merkel
erklärt rechtfertigt verteidigt auch
warum restaurants und theater schließen
müssen läden aber geöffnet bleiben kann
die antwort nur sein wenn es heißt ihr
habt restaurants geschlossen und bars
und geschäfte nicht das ist nicht
gerecht dass wir dann auch die geschäfte
schließen müssen
die antwort kann nicht sagen wir machen
beides wieder auf dann laufen wir in den
ruin
die kanzlerin warnt auch im dezember
werde noch nicht die normalität
einkehren wie man sie vor corona kannte
es wird ein weihnachten unter corona
bedingung sein aber es soll kein
weihnachten in einsamkeit sein
ein auftritt der den politischen wie dem
öffentlichen druck geschuldet ist es
wird nicht der letzte gewesen sein
in diesen corona zeiten deutschland
fährt runter gleich nach den heute
nachrichten gibt es ein zdf spezial zur
corona krise und was gilt genau bis ende
november
punkt für punkt noch einmal nachlesen
können sie das in unserer zdf heute app
einen blick auf die korona zahlen für
deutschland der trend bei den
neuinfektionen weist im wochenvergleich
weiter nach oben
im sieben tage schnitt steckten sich
täglich durchschnittlich 16 1340
menschen neu mit dem virus an
gestern lag der schnitt noch bei 13 1860
die neuen verschärfungen in der korona
pandemie sollen vor allem eines bringen
die zahl der neuinfektionen wirksam
begrenzen
eine besondere herausforderung bleiben
dabei die klassenzimmer in den schulen
hier gibt es jetzt eine kostengünstige
technische lösung die hoffnungen weckt
abluftanlagen angriff hat hat sie sich
angeschaut
angst vor einer kurve 19 ansteckung im
unterricht haben diese schüler der
integrierten gesamtschule in mainz
bretzenheim kaum noch sie sitzen unter
einer abluftanlage die die gefürchteten
er o sohle im klassenraum drastisch
reduzieren soll
ich denke dass man dadurch besser ist
und dass es jeder merkt die
luftzirkulation besser wird und dass wir
nicht immer und die fenster öffnen
müssen und dass wir das vermeiden können
dass die schulen wieder teilweise
geschlossen werden
forscher des max-planck-instituts für
chemie haben diese abluftanlage zusammen
mit der schule entwickelt
menschen geben wärme ab entsprechend
kommt es über den schülern zu
luftströmungen er o sohle werden mit
nach oben getragen
dunstabzugshauben saugen die schadstoffe
ab durch ein rohrsystem wird die
belastete luft nach draußen geleitet
ein ventilator am fenster sorgt für die
nötigen sog ohne die dunstabzugshauben
kommen wir schon in den bereich dass wir
ungefähr drei viertel aller schadstoffe
eliminieren können und mit denen
dunstabzugshauben liegen wir irgendwo
über 90 prozent
die forscher waren nach ihren messungen
selbst überrascht dass es so gut
funktioniert ein weiteres plus alle
materialien sind im baumarkt erhältlich
kosten pro klassenraum unter 200 euro
das ziel ist es die ganze zeit gewesen
ein bausatz system das vielleicht sogar
idealerweise schüler umsetzen kann in
einer projektwoche herzustellen
das ist wirklich denkbar einfach solch
eine anlage in jedem schulraum zu
installieren auch virologen sehen in dem
kostengünstigen system eine echte
alternative
in vielen situationen wird es nicht
möglich sein sich für 34 5000 euro
geräte in innenräume zu stellen um aero
solar auszufiltern und daher sind
günstige möglichkeiten die ähnlich
effektiv sind durchaus wünschenswert
eine einfache lösung die bundesweit
schule machen könnte
nach china dort beobachten experten dass
man die rezession offenbar nur
erfolgreich bekämpfen kann wenn man den
kampf gegen das virus gewonnen hat die
stimmung in der wirtschaft ist nach
einer umfrage sogar auf ein
zehnjahreshoch gestiegen und das obwohl
noch im frühjahr
bilder von provisorischen corona
krankenhäusern und abgesperrten
stadtvierteln die berichterstattung
projekten
jetzt feiern die chinesen wieder ulf
röller
es sind bilder die china gerne der
ganzen welt zeigen will wo an der ort
der für den ausbruch des virus steht
feiert eine wilde party
krankenschwestern als zombies soziale
distanz brauchen sie hier nicht mehr
während in europa die infektionszahlen
dramatisch steigen kehrt in china alltag
ein
ich habe keine angst weil chinas virus
control system sehr gut ist jeder muss
seine gesundheits app zeigen jeder passt
auf mehr als zwei monate war woran die
fast elf millionen metropole im lotto
china reagierte auf das virus mit
dramatischen maßnahmen totale kontrolle
wie es nur ein überwachungsstaat volkan
die gesundheits app verrät den staat
immer wo jeder gerade gewesen ist bis
heute sind die menschen sehr vorsichtig
viele trauen dem corona triumph nicht
ganz ich habe ein wenig angst aber diese
feier ist eine der seltenen
gelegenheiten an einem festival
teilzunehmen
ich nehme ein gewisses risiko auf mich
presse den schinken glaubt chinas
autoritäres system seit dem
demokratischen überlegen die beliebten
straßen pekings seien der beweis dafür
wie hier in peking herrscht in den
meisten städten normalität man geht
davon aus dass das virus besiegt es
darauf sind die chinesen stolz und wenn
es überhaupt noch eine corona gefahr
gibt dann kommt sie aus dem ausland
während das virus viele länder im griff
hat genießt china die korona freie zeit
morgen ist es nun soweit wahltag in den
usa präsident trump erklärte zum
wahlkampfabschluss er wolle sich bei
einem eigenen vorsprung noch in der
wahlnacht zum sieger erklären
man werde sich die wahl nicht stehlen
lassen entgegnet herausforderer beiden
und setzt auch bei der auswertung der
briefwahl die länger dauern könne auch
viele stimmen gewählt wird in insgesamt
50 bundesstaaten in den meisten davon
erwarten die wahlbeobachter keine
überraschung weil traditionell eines der
lager dort die mehrheit hat entscheiden
dürften dagegen die sogenannten swing
states werden
hier wurde in den vergangenen jahren mal
für die demokraten mal für die
republikaner gestimmt noch ist offen
welcher der beiden kandidaten am ende
alle wahlmänner und frauen dort für sich
gewinnen kann
florida ist einer dieser swing states
und einer der bedeutendsten denn hier
gibt es mit 29 wahlleuten relativ viel
zu gewinnen
unsere reporterin anne brühl war dort
und hat sich umgehört
der sheriff ist schon da so angespannt
ist die lage in panels county vor ein
paar tagen gab es hier im bezirk an
vorfall mit trump anhängern die sich als
sicherheitsleute ausgegeben hatten
seitdem steht vor jedem wahllokal die
polizeibehörde bereiten wir uns auf
alles vor sicherheit von leib und leben
cyber sicherheit dass wir unsere wähler
vor einschüchterung und unterdrückung
schützen
all das berücksichtigen wir und es gibt
pläne damit wir das entschärfen können
der senioren latinos weiße junge die
wählergruppen in florida sind sehr
unterschiedlich und immer wieder gibt es
demografische verschiebungen das macht
es so schwer das wahlverhalten
vorauszusagen
ich möchte versuchen trump abzuwählen
ich denke er hat in letzter zeit
schlechte entscheidungen getroffen
ich bin sehr besorgt über sozialismus zb
der zum kommunismus führt ich denke
alles was dieses land großartig macht
ist anpacken und hart arbeiten
drinnen werden schon die
briefwahlstimmen ausgezählt die parteien
haben wahlbeobachter geschickt die
technik ist neu
chaos bei der auszählung wollen sie in
pinal county unbedingt vermeiden
das könnte wieder einmal ganz knapp
werden hier in florida letzte umfragen
sehen beide kandidaten kopf an kopf
besonders für donald trump geht es um
alles oder nichts
er muss florida gewinnen um am ende noch
eine chance auf den sieg zu haben
joe biden oder donald trump in florida
machen die unterstützer wahlkampf bis
zum schluss es kommt auf jede stimme an
zurück nach deutschland
im hafen von nordenham in niedersachsen
ist ein umstrittener castor-transport
aus der britischen
wiederaufarbeitungsanlage sellafield
eingetroffen
voraussichtlich morgen sollen die sechs
behälter mit radioaktivem atommüll mit
dem zug zum zwischenlager im hessischen
biblis weiter transportiert werden
der müll aus sellafield stammt
ursprünglich aus deutschen
atomkraftwerken
am letzten schultag vor den herbstferien
in frankreich wurde der lehrer samuel
partie von einem islamisten enthauptet
heute gut zwei wochen später geht die
schule wieder los mit einer
schweigeminute für samuel partie der im
unterricht beim thema meinungsfreiheit
mohammed-karikaturen gezeigt hatte
christel hass berichtet
schwer bewaffnete polizisten stehen vor
vielen schulen an diesem ersten tag nach
den ferien
heute ist nicht so wie immer heute geht
es um den islamistischen anschlag auf
einen lehrer
wir lehrer versuchen die allgemeine
besorgnis nicht auf die kinder zu
übertragen
und diesen schuh tag so friedlich wie
möglich zu gestalten drinnen wird über
meinungsfreiheit gesprochen über
karikaturen über hass und terror das was
sie dem lehrer angetan haben ist nicht
gut das dürfen sie nicht er hat das
recht zu sagen was er will
wir haben über das geredet was in der
welt passiert über die trennung von
kirche und staat und über glaubensfragen
es war eine kleine debatte dann um 11
uhr schweigeminute für samuel partie den
ermordeten lehrer in allen schulen
frankreichs auch in dieser muslimischen
schule als muslim hat man kein recht
jemanden zu töten auch wenn man mohammed
karikaturen nicht mag das ist absolut
verboten
samuel partie hatte in seinem unterricht
solche karikaturen gezeigt als es um
meinungsfreiheit ging deshalb wurde er
von einem islamistischen attentäter
enthauptet das trifft frankreich ins
mark vor vier tagen dann ein neuer
tödlicher messerangriff in einer
basilika in nizza heute zeigen die
schulen dass sie aufstehen gegen
radikalisierung und hass und dass sie
sich die meinungsfreiheit nicht nehmen
lassen auch in zahlreichen deutschen
schulen schweigeminute und gedenken an
den enthaupteten lehrer zum beispiel in
wiesbaden
aufstehen und innehalten als zeichen der
solidarität mit allen die sich im
unterricht für toleranz und eine offene
gesellschaft einsetzen
lehrer und eltern betonten es sei
unverzichtbar unterrichten zu können
ohne sich bedroht zu fühlen
drei tage nach dem schweren erdbeben in
der ägäis ist die zahl der todesopfer
auf mindestens 87 gestiegen und die
hoffnung schwindet noch überlebende zu
finden
dennoch konnten rettungskräfte in der
türkischen stadt ist mir ein
dreijähriges mädchen aus den trümmern
befreien
auch eine 14-jährige wurde gerettet
beide waren rund 60 stunden von schutt
eingeschlossen in der nähe von rotterdam
in den niederlanden ist eine u-bahn
verunglückt was dem fahrer aber wohl das
leben rettete ist kaum zu glauben
die bahn krachte durch eine absperrung
und wäre zehn meter in die tiefe
gefallen doch die riesige schwanzflosse
eines wals hielt sie in der luft
die skulptur aus kunststoff ist bereits
20 jahre alt und sinnigerweise heißt sie
vom schwanz eines wals gerettet tolle
geschichte sie zitieren aber in münster
fußball champions league und zum fc
bayern ja und der könnte schon morgen
abend mit einem sieg in salzburg das
achtelfinal-ticket lösen
eigentlich alles prima wäre da nicht der
wirbel um david alaba denn die bayern
bosse die haben ihr vertragsangebot an
ihren abwehrchef zurückgezogen
ausgerechnet vor dem spiel war seinen
landsleuten in salzburg bringen
nachrichten um david alaba unruhe
nach einem längerem feilschen um einen
neuen vertrag haben die münchner ihr
angebot nun zurückgezogen
alabas agent soll 20 millionen euro
jahresgehalt gefordert haben dann jeden
einzeln versichern dass zum beispiel die
summen die in den raum gestellt werden
dass das nicht der wahrheit entspricht
ich bin alles andere als glücklich dass
wir uns mit diesem thema in der woche wo
wir zwei sehr schwere spiele in
salzburgern in dortmund haben damit
befassen müssen
zumal mit niklas süle ein weiterer
wichtiger abwehrspieler fehlen wird er
muss nach positiven corona test in
quarantäne der weltsport blickt gespannt
nach lausanne und zum internationalen
sportgerichtshof cas
russland hat dort einspruch gegen den
vierjährigen ausschluss von top
spitzensport ereignissen eingelegt diese
strafe hatte die
welt-anti-doping-agentur wada im
dezember 2019 verhängt nach der
aufdeckung von russischen staatsdoping
wird diese sperre nun bestätigt wäre
dies für russland unter anderem das aus
bei olympia in tokio und peking und bei
der fußball wm in katar unser experte
markus harm beobachtet diese verhandlung
markus mit welchem urteil rechnen sie
viele experten fordern eine vier jahre
schwere sagen es wäre ein verheerendes
signal würde russland erneut nicht
richtig bestraft werden so zum beispiel
richard pound ioc-mitglied denn es war
nicht nur ein staatlich organisiertes
doping system sondern die russen haben
auch nach 2019 weiter betrogen daten
manipuliert so die wada viele sportler
weltweit wollen auch endlich harte
strafen nach dem ewigen hin und her in
der russischen doping- saga die deutsche
athleten vertretung spricht sogar von
einem total versagen des welt- anti-
doping systems sollte es eine aufhebung
der sperre geben kaum ein athlet hätte
dann noch vertrauen
es ist also wirklich der wohl wichtigste
doping prozess in der sportpolitik danke
markus haben und bis zur
urteilsverkündung dürfte es allerdings
noch ein paar wochen dauern
spannt danken arbeit eines der wenigen
symbole für erfolgreiche weltweite
zusammenarbeit feiert heute seinen 20
geburtstag
die internationale raumstation iss am 2
november 2000 waren sie die ersten zwei
russische kosmonauten und ein
amerikanischer
laut dass außerirdische teamwork klappt
bis heute prächtig zur zeit rast
besatzung nummer 63 alle eineinhalb
stunden einmal um die erde
ja und auf der erde war es heute
ungewöhnlich warm mit temperaturen über
20 grad wie der november weitergeht sagt
uns gleich katja honnefer das war es von
uns schön dass sie dabei waren
im heute-journal erwartet sie marietta
slomka um 21.45 und wir sind morgen
wieder für sie da punkt 7 noch einen
schönen abend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren wenn an den
bäumen nicht so viele braune blätter
hängen dann könnten wir fast annehmen
das hier ist ein bilder aus dem frühling
oder aus dem sommer
es ist aber exakt zwei tage alt da gab
es viel sonnenschein und heute kam
nochmal die wärme 20 jahre 23 grad gab
es in deutschland vielleicht für ihrer
haustür sogar 24 grad
jetzt aber kommt eine kleine kaltfront
die hängt zusammen mit dem tief nina und
dahinter wird es deutlich kühler
da liegen die temperaturen meist nur
noch knapp über 10 grad
heute nacht bleibt es aber noch mild bei
13 bis 10 grad in der südosthälfte etwas
kühler wird es schon hinter der kalte
und im nordwesten mit 9 bis 6 grad also
einstellig und damit ist auch ganz klar
wo die kaltfront liegt nämlich ungefähr
zwischen dem oberrhein und dem
erzgebirge dahinter lockern die wolken
auf aber an der nordsee da kann es bei
böigem westwind westen durchaus einige
regenschauer geben
morgen ziehen sich die regenwolken immer
weiter an den alpenrand zurück und dann
wird das ein freundlicher dienstag genau
deutschland bei einem südwestwind und
die temperaturen morgen sind längst
nicht mehr so hoch wie heute
uns erwarten dann werte von 10 bis 15
grad und es geht mit ruhigem
herbstwetter weiter am freitag bei
temperaturen von neun bis dreizehn
schönen abend noch